coral reefs are one of the most
important ecosystems on earth they
protect shorelines provide valuable
habitat for wildlife and keep the oceans
nutrients in balance but they're also
under threat
Corie surround the world are facing
overfishing dynamic fishing of cyanide
fishing increased sea surface
temperatures and ocean acidification
physically a lot of these stressors
manifest themselves in color in the
pieces of coral being broken off or
entire corals just collapsing for
decades scientists have lacked the
fundamental ability of tracking coral
reef growth they've attempted to analyze
this through 2d measurements such as a
measurement tape or a regazzi chain
which estimates the 2d structure or
surface area with the attempts to
extrapolate and understand the bigger 3d
structures but they're all very
antiquated and they're all very
imprecise in the last couple of years
hardware devices that enable us to
capture the analog world around us and
then digitize it to bring it in
computers have become so ubiquitous that
we realize many new professionals can
actually leverage these technologies to
push their professions to the limits so
I started working on a software that
will make high quality results from any
type of capture beads the photos or
scans but it is designed with scientists
and curators and artists in mind who do
not have experience in a 3d geeky
digital world to create these models
essentially every feature we want to
show up in the 3d model has to be
captured you think a picture usually
about every 5 degrees and almost like
with the paintbrush just make sure
you're painted in from all corners after
we take the photographs they're post
processed for color saturation clarity
they're then uploaded to the cloud or we
work with new reality capture technology
to not only create the mesh but also
produce them for 3d printing and also
exporting them for visualizations online
I think the power of this technology of
reality capture will be fully realized
once it gets in the hands of citizen
scientists people that aren't scientists
in their everyday job hopefully one day
we'll have all of the world's quarries
captured so anyone can go online explore
them interact with them and ultimately
understand them